Kanye West's piss and no one with  authority at Adidas is safe he's coming  for all of them Kanye is accusing Adidas  for stealing his designs and he also  said that Adidas is offering him a one  billion dollar buyout and now Kanye  wants out of the contract similarly to  how he went after Nike CEO Mark Parker  back in 2013. he posted a fake New York  Times article announcing the death of  Adidas CEO Kanye is also posted most of  the Adidas leadership board with  captions that Instagram later to take  down basil went against their guidelines  Kanye also says that Yeezy is 68 of  Adidas online sales and he's saying  whether Adidas keeps him or lets him go  it's gonna cost them billions